my wonderful co-star Florence Pugh was
she's terrific I mean she is a she's a
Powerhouse she's she's already done
incredible work and I'm sure we'll do uh
more
um so she's she Bears everything in the
film and no one talks about it and I
thought to myself how interesting that
so does no one talk about the fact that
she Bears everything because it's
expected of a woman to do that in film
or that there's a sense of decorm that
one wouldn't say that to a woman about
having done that and yet these pithy
Commons can be made about me which I
don't care about but I think there's a
more interesting conversation to be had
about well why is why is the case that
men don't do it or there's not expected
of a man to do it or it's taken a long
time but I guess the question is that
why